I will not see it ended on the account
of this head
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my Full House of the Dragon
episode 8 video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them and careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll
just start at the beginning of the
episode and work our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs WTF
moments starting with the episode title
the lord of the tides which is a
reference to the lord of House Valerian
and driftmark because in this episode
cordless valerian's brother Raymond is
challenging for his claim to driftmark
he wants to assert his claim over
Rainier's son luceras who Corliss wanted
to inherit in rainey's Choice who's
clearly Baylor that's the whole reason
why she took her to Ward with her the
past six years the only big additions
that I could detect in the opening title
sequence were the line between Ranier
and Damon to represent their marriage
which they did in last week's episode
and the new lines from her representing
the children that they've had together
since then and she's pregnant with her
third child with him in the episode I'll
talk about them in a second so pretty
soon she's gonna have six kids her first
child with Damon is aegon III who they
introduced to viserys the second child I
think is more poignant because his name
is viserys II she names him visares
after her father viserys who he also got
to meet before he died in this episode
the actual opening scene takes place on
driftmark with rhaenys sitting in for
Corliss while he's been fighting down in
the stepstones but they did explain that
they won back the stepsons in the
previous conflict remember they were
worried about a big war starting with
Doran potentially in the triarchy since
then they explained that they've retaken
the stepstones but the triarchy has
resurged and then tried to take back the
stepstones from Corliss Valerian is how
he got injured this is the older version
of Bayla we also meet older Arena later
in the episode remember they're meant to
be twins but they style their hairs
differently so it's a little bit easier
to tell them apart on screen did a real
quick blink and you'll miss it Brienne
of Tarth reference when they reference
Evan fall that's actually the seat of
house Tardis So eventually later in the
timeline Brienne of Tarth is born and
raised there when Bayman starts arguing
with rainey's about the succession she
mentions no talk of crow which is
another Feast for Crow's reference they
literally reference a fees for Crows
like someone actually said the words a
feast four crows in a previous episode
too obviously the big conflict in this
episode is him really not liking renera
in the fact that her children are
bastards in his petition with the Iron
Throne the big problem with runera is
that even though she doesn't really care
that much about drift Mark or its
Holdings like she doesn't want it for
herself or her family or anything like
that she's not mad with power in that
way she's more worried that calling the
legitimacy of her children into question
will further cause questions on her
legitimacy for the Iron Throne so she's
really worried about the Iron Throne
when Bayman says that it's a queen who
sits the Iron Throne these days not a
king that's a reference to Allison even
though they transitioned directly to
Dragonstone because technically Rainier
is the current Heir and going to become
Queen eventually even though the end of
the episode makes you think that it's
going to end very differently there's a
lot of moments like that in this episode
where you think things are a done deal
like the best laid plans and obviously
things go completely off the rails and
none of those plans come to fruition
Andre Dragonstone Damon climbs the rocks
of the mountains into the caves where
the dragons lay their eggs in cyrox has
laid a new clutch of dragon eggs which
they referenced in a previous episode
when Rainier was trying to betray
jakiris to Helena Targaryen they
actually referenced that later in the
episode too when they're dancing
together in front of viserys like oh
they could have been king and queen when
they were all younger raniera said if
Cyrax lays another clutch of dragon eggs
then Eamon would have his choice of any
of those eggs this time Damon grabs a
new one it looks pretty fresh like it's
still smoking when he prys it out and
it's meant to be another callback to him
trying to take a dragon egg in episode
two obviously that was a big faint
though like he hadn't actually gotten
this area pregnant but this time he has
three legitimate very legitimate
children with renira who by the laws of
their house in the realm just in general
are entitled to dragon eggs dragon eggs
to their family are more precious than
gold it's like giving a child a nuclear
weapon even though he says that Cyrax
has three new dragon eggs he only takes
one of them that's for their newest
child who's going to be named visenya
their oldest is named aegon III the
second is named viserys II after her
father and the third is named visenya
for aegon the conqueror's sister wife
vicenya so the idea is that Damon wants
to put this Dragon egg in vicenya's crib
when she's eventually born also him
mentioning that Cyrax had three dragon
eggs is another reference to Daenerys
but daenerys's dragon eggs actually
probably came from dreamfire Helena's
Dragon because later in the timeline
there were three dragon eggs that were
stolen from dreamfire's clutch in
physically dream fire resembles Daenerys
dragons in the map table room jakaris is
learning High Valerian that sounds like
he just started and he's getting a
history lesson from this maester about
the path of aegon the Conqueror during
the conquest making first landfall at
what eventually became King's Landing
that's what he's referencing when they
talk about him felling the trees what
happened was as the aegon and the
Conqueror made landfall in the area that
they just renamed to King's Landing
later after he won the war of Conquest
the city was sort of built up around
that place but until then it was really
just a military fort that they called
aegon fort in fact after the high septon
crowned aegon king of Westeros he went
and ruled from the aegon fort for the
rest of his life the actual red key like
the big castle that you see in present
day was actually built by maegor much
later in the timeline near the fire you
notice baby Joffrey no longer quite the
baby with one of the servants I think
the picture book that he's reading from
is another picture book about aegon the
Conqueror when she mentions that she's
going to be deposed that's also a
reference to what happens at the end of
the episode with the idea that Allison
thinks that aegon II has been named air
in the greens this is their faction in
the dance of the Dragons is basically
going to pull a coup in next week's
episode and try to name aegon II the
official King when they arrive back at
the red keep they're greeted by Lord
Caswell if you remember he was the
person that greeted rhaenyra on the
stairs when she had just given birth to
baby Joffrey asking her if she needed
any help anything at all just let me
know in the future that was a reference
to the eventual coming of the dance of
the dragons like he'll probably declare
for the blacks that's another really
interesting thing in the episode too
based on what color you see people
wearing in the episode that basically
lets you know who they're going to
declare for when the battle lines are
actually drawn so for instance rhaenys
is wearing black the entire episode
during the episode she basically
declares her support for renero the same
is true for a lot of The Other Side
characters too in the background that
don't have a lot of speaking lines in
the episode they also take note that
Allison has swapped in a bunch of
symbols of the faith of the seven for
all the Targaryen heraldry she's also
wearing the seven-pointed star around
her neck on a chain the reason for that
is because her family has this long
history with the faith of the seven
remember they're from Old Town and
before aegon's Conquest the faith of the
seven was centered in Old Town so for
thousands of years their family was very
close to the faith of the seven itself
and she's always believed in the faith
but it sounds like she's become way more
devout in her older age it's also a
reference to what happened with tommen
later during the events of the main show
too when the faith of the seven
basically kind of took over Tom and kind
of co-opted him and they replaced a lot
of heraldry around the red keep with
symbols of of the faith itself it's just
meant to show you the growing influence
of the faith of the seven in the realm
that'll become a bigger thing during the
events of this show which I'll talk
about in future Seasons because I think
some of it won't be paid off till like
Season Two Season three they also
reference during the small council
meeting that a lot of the members of the
faith are requesting more funds from the
crown that's going to become a big
problem in the future like they're just
kind of seeding a lot of this faith of
the seven plot in the background now
they pay off the reference about the
queen sitting the Iron Throne when we
see Allison sitting at the head of the
small Council because of what's happened
with viserys him becoming so infirm when
Thailand Lannister mentions jacarus's
Dragon that's Vermax who's gotten much
bigger since the last episode but he's
still relatively small compared to the
other dragons the other members of the
small Council also make reference to him
being a bastard without actually coming
out and saying it out loud clearly the
members of the small Council want to
declare for vaman like they don't want
to have anything to do with renera's
children I'll talk about this more in a
second too because it has a lot to do
with the way that Allison is taking all
this and playing the Game of Thrones so
to speak because it seems that she
really does not like playing the game of
Thrones whereas her father Otto
Hightower is really trying to push her
around the board so to speak the way
that he pushed her around when she was
younger like why don't you go spend some
more time with viserys when Rainier goes
to see her father they show the ancient
Valerian model has cobwebs all over it
this book is probably another history
book about ancient Valeria just showing
you that it's been a long time since
he's actually worked on his model
because his condition has gotten so much
worse he's almost like a living corpse
at this point which is why I was really
surprised that he died at the end of
this episode and not an episode nine
like I was expecting like one more
episode out of him he's been kind of
like the Sean Bean of the show so you're
just kind of waiting for him to die like
when is it going to happen because the
actual conflict that dance of the
Dragons doesn't really start till his
actual death they use their conversation
to set up a lot of what happens at the
end of the episode too where he confuses
Allison with rhaenyra and just confuses
the two different versions of aegon so
Allison thinks that he's really talking
about aegon II when he was actually
thinking that he was talking to renera
about aegon's prophecy of A Song of Ice
and Fire where aegon saw up at the North
they're careful to highlight the fact
that he's got got so much milk of the
poppy in his tea like his quote unquote
tea is addling his brain so to speak but
that's because he's in a constant state
of pain like they're very careful to
show you how much pain he experiences
just trying to walk around or even speak
to someone is also meant to be a mirror
for Allison with the moon T later with
the servant girl who's gotten pregnant
with aegon the seconds bastard which is
also meant to be a callback to renera's
Moon T in the earlier episode when the
grand maester prepared the same thing
for her and if it wasn't clear Allison
is genuinely sympathetic to her plight
she totally believes her like oh yeah my
son definitely forced himself on this
girl poor girl that's why she gives her
that lump of gold in the moon tea just
to let her know oh we're not going to
have you killed but you definitely have
to leave the red keep but isn't it
ironic that she's now facing the same
situation that she had been so upset at
renera for previously aegon II Breaking
All the Rules but because she wants to
uphold the status quo this whole
question of the bastards and who becomes
the next king she's kind of forced to
live with it which is why she kicks
around aegon II so much like you're no
son of mine you're such a terrible
person it's also a call back to Cersei
and Joffrey with the way that Cersei
loved Joffrey but he was a terrible
person and she had trouble controlling
him the big difference with aegon II is
that he clearly wants nothing to do with
being King it's like he's pulling a Jon
Snow here I don't want it him sleeping
with the servant girls and being drunk
most of the time is also right out of
the books too like he was very fond of
drink that only got worse when he got
older and he really really loved getting
with the servant girls and I love the
irony of the moment when Helena walks in
asking what happened to the servant girl
that she just had to get rid of because
of the bastard child what happened to
her she was supposed to get the children
ready that's a reference to her
legitimate children that she had with
aegon II remember Allison betrothed them
previously and since then she's had
three children with him it's jahiris
Jahira and mailor maybe we'll see them
in season two they're also meant to be
very young and she makes some jokes
about being married to him later in the
episode too after he makes a bunch of
jokes at jakaris about still being a
virgin raniera and Allison have their
big reunion scene and they just show you
the things are are still pretty tense
between them even though they cooled off
quite a bit there's just a little
acrimonious at this point early in the
episode but it does seem for a brief hot
second that they actually might mend
their fences until the end of the
episode when she first walks in too
they're careful to focus the camera on
her scar that's left over from the
Valerian dagger like oh the last time we
met as they focus on the scar the boys
go back to the yard and see the old
practice damage all the fun that they
used to get up to they talk about
Kristen Cole's Morning Star the one that
he's currently fighting with Eamon
practicing with that's the same weapon
that he fought Damon with during the
tourney at the beginning of the series
and obviously all the children are older
in this episode so we have the much
older version of aemond who seems like
now he loves violence and I think that's
why he tells Kristen Cole that he
doesn't care about tourneys because when
vaman walks in he perks up or any time
he thinks that a fight is about to break
out he perks up later in the episode in
fact at the dinner table later when they
avert a conflict early on he seems
really crestfall and like oh I was
hoping for a fight that's mostly
foreshadowing for what he'll be like
during the actual conflict later I don't
think he's a total madman or anything
like that I think that he just loves
violence now like he's become very
Twisted in the years since the last
episode back in the godswood Ranier and
rhaenys betrothed all their children
together although they don't seal the
deal to the actual meeting later like
rainey's declaring it in front of the
king is her basically saying oh yes I
agree to all your terms we also finally
see the older version of Reina in the
way that reynus talks about it it sounds
like Reyna stayed on Dragonstone with
Damon because that's her father so only
Bayla has been on driftmark these past
six years as rainey's Ward the fact
she's wearing black here early in the
episode is also meant to foreshadow her
eventually declaring her support for
rhaenyra really interesting to note that
rhaenys still thinks that rhaenyra was
responsible for laner's death and when
she denies it in the episode like I had
nothing to do with your son's death
she's not lying because later is still
alive we'll see if she ever learns the
truth in the future you can let me know
in the comments if you think that Ranier
will eventually tell her no no your
son's actually alive there's always the
possibility that laner Aaron could come
back in the future pretending to be
somebody different and just helping them
during the actual battles but the whole
idea is that jakaris is going to marry
Reyna and luceris will marry Bela so
that rhaenys will get all the things
that she originally wanted viserys
continues to confuse rhaenyra with
Allison further setting up the confusion
at the end of the episode the other
interesting moment here too is renera
basically telling viserys that she
doesn't want the Iron Throne like I'm
tired of all the drama she pulls a Jon
Snow I don't want it this episode was
full of people saying that they did not
want the Iron Throne also the smoke
coming from the model of ancient valyria
as he's being treated for his wounds in
the Bell tolling is foreshadowing for
his death like they would light the
smoke and ring the bell to mark his
passing in the naming of the new King
which it sounds like will happen in next
week's episode also love the way they
transitioned to the overhead shot of the
iron throne in what's happening because
of the whole Battle of the succession
that's happening on the show right now
there's so many metaphors in this shot
too like there's so much that you could
take out of this particular scene the
way that they filmed it during the
petition vaman made takes all these
references to the histories of both
House Targaryen and house Valerian I
talked a lot about those histories in my
previous videos so I'll link those Below
in the description he also keeps talking
about Bloodlines and the purity of his
blood for those of you wondering why
Damon was laughing during the funeral
scene in the previous episode that's
also the reason why he was laughing
because during vaman's speech a lot of
what he was saying was about being pure
of blood so Damon was laughing about him
trying to secretly knock runera's
children being bastards and now he's
just doing it in a much more open way
when he says he could cut his veins and
show them his blood that's obviously
foreshadowing for Damon doing exactly
that ending the matter and when viserys
walks in to preside over the meeting not
on the Milk of the poppy like clear of
mind you need to take note of the way
that Alison reacts to a lot of this
because she seems so worried about
what's going to happen to him and the
pain that he's in if he didn't realize
Allison was also the final caretaker for
King jiharis before visares so during
his final days Allison watched over King
jahiris the same way that she's is
watching over King viserys so watching
him waste away is really painful for her
having to relive a lot of the memories
of what it was like watching King
jiharis waste away so they do want you
to sympathize with a lot of her wanting
to give him that milk of the poppy even
though it does Addle his brain and cause
a lot of confusion in the worst possible
way at the end of the episode The Crown
falling off his head and Damon picking
it up is more of a callback to previous
episodes with him wanting the throne for
himself but he's clearly very sad about
what's happened to his brother rainey's
speech about the succession over drift
markers her basically agreeing to all of
raniero's terms like oh and by the way
they're all going to get married when
you look at everybody's reactions to a
lot of this before things go off the
rails aegon II Smiles a little bit
that's because he feels like things are
settled and he doesn't have to worry
about becoming King likes oh thank God
it doesn't have to be me obviously he
spoke too soon because it sounds like
they're going to force him to put the
crown on in next week's episode drag him
Kicking and Screaming to the Iron Throne
love the way that Damon eggs him on and
the way they pay off this moment about
taking his tongue oh he can keep his
tongue and like I said you look at
eamon's reaction he seems enthralled by
the sight of all this violence like oh
this is amazing let's do more of this
big big red flags coming from Eamonn in
this episode the scene of both of the
women in frame of the Iron Throne the
blacks versus The Greens the succession
all reference to the coming dance the
dragons and the conflict starting in
next week's episode then the scene of
rhaenys watching The Silent sisters
prepare vaman's body I think it's just a
way to honor him and honor all the dead
people that she's known like she
references all the dead people she's
lost to the maester then I love this
dinner scene so when viserys walks in
sitting between the women even though it
starts kind of tense for a while in the
episode you think like it all might be
okay viserys is getting everything that
he wanted everybody is making nice
making peace with each other the cane
that he's using there looks like it has
a little dragon head on it and then if
things actually went off the rails it
was really mostly the kid's fault like
fighting the way that you would expect
kids to fight aegon making fun of
jacares for being a virgin then Helena
making fun of aegon for being a bad
husband but near analysis seemed like
they temporarily set aside their
differences and it almost works like for
a little while rhaenyra is planning on
coming back and spending time with her
like they used to when they were younger
when they were best friends it even
sounds like they were almost leveraged
at one point too when she says she's
going to return to the red keep on
Dragon back that's obviously herd
thinking that she's going to just come
back really fast on her own but really
it's a reference to her coming to the
red keep on Dragon back with fire like I
will come back and it will be War they
make another pink dread joke when they
serve the pig to aemond he makes another
strong boy's joke to jakaris and luceris
inside No 2 Helena's comments when she
says beware the Beast beneath the boards
that's not a dragon dream because like
when she was younger she spoke all in
Prophecy she still has Dragon dreams but
the Beast beneath the boars is just a
reference to aegon sleeping with all the
servants like beware of aegon trying to
sleep with you but the Beast beneath the
boards is literally like the Beast
Within aegon's pants when Damon diffuses
the tension at the end of the episode
before the kids break into all-out fight
and you see this seen between him and
Eamonn that's also a reference to them
later in the godswood but that won't
happen until like season three maybe so
I'll just wait to talk about that till
later but eventually they will go at
each other on Dragon back Missouri comes
back into the story remember she's kind
of like a version of Varys she has
little birds and it turns out the woman
who informed Allison about what happened
with aegon in his bastard and the
servant girl is working for messeria so
when she says oh it sounds like things
were busy at the red keep today it's
just to let you know that Miss area
knows everything that's been going on
this entire time she'll have much more
influence on the actual plot in future
Seasons then at the end of the episode
obviously he speaks to Allison about
aegon's prophecy about the long night
believing that she's rhaenyra and she
being someone who is Hardcore about Duty
and honor that's why she got so pissed
off at renera when they were younger
believes that he's forcing her to unite
The Realm by naming aegon II to the iron
throne and she thinks that she's going
to honor his wishes like do right by him
by completing that so that's what she
means when she says I understand what
you mean and I will do it she thinks
that she's honoring his memory doing the
right thing when really he was talking
about aegon the Conqueror and she just
confused it thinking that he was talking
about aegon II also love the way they
end this shot on the Valerian dagger
like ooh this is not going to end well
which is also a callback to the conflict
in episode 7 with her attacking renera
with the Valyrian dagger then he dies
the king is dead along live the king his
dying last words are my love and that's
him greeting his original wife Emma
remember he confused Allison for Emma in
last week's episode too she was the love
of his alive so it's like he's greeting
her seeing her again in death it was a
great episode if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video
just write down below in the comments in
my episode 9 trailer video we'll post
next so make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that but
basically this is the actual start of
the real dance of the Dragons everyone
click here for that episode 9 trailer
video I'll update the link as soon as I
post that and click here for all my
other house of the dragon videos thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next
one